Charles Barkley kind enough to join us
Charles good morning what did you make
of last night's performance I thought it
was awesome the championship going to
Toronto it's great I think it's great
for the NBA and man what a run of a
kalenna
it's one of the greatest runs we've ever
had
going back to Orlando Philly Milwaukee
right up there with dirt and event ski
trying to think obviously Michael havoc
some runs but it's one of the great runs
of all time
I mean it's hard to put into words what
you saw the last two months I mean like
I say Dirk care at a team Mike obviously
did it a few times you know all those
other great players had a lot more help
well even Michael had Scottie and yeah
but it ain't the same it was a good
player don't get me wrong but this guy
there's not another hall-of-famer on
that team yeah you know bird McHale I
mean Bird and Magic those guys had three
or four Hall of Famers but I don't mean
in a disrespect to any player but what
he carried was a lot different I mean
it's one of the great runs I've ever
seen like I say Dirk Nowitzki is
probably coming I think I was one of the
great runs I've ever seen and he went
through a great heap team to get that
championship I did he did what do a
great team that's what I'm saying is
it's a small list Dirk Kawai you know it
was awesome do we put an asterisk by
this the way we did like the Rockets
when they won their titles
everybody says yeah but Mike was playing
baseball then when the Bulls beat the
Lakers and magic was injured do we do
that are we gonna do that is history
gonna look back and go yeah but Golden
State was all banged up and not that if
I'm a raptor fan I don't care you can
put whatever you want next to it we
still want a championship but is is
history kind to the wrapped
with pulling off this surprise we're all
idiots and fools things like that yeah
you know can't think Kenny's happy with
his two rings I think Michaels happy one
this ring with magic pull his hamstring
I think Byron Scott did also listen if
you know you just have been pessimistic
if you can't give Kawhi Leonard what you
just saw the last two months
you know he's back into the basin's the
best player in NBA I mean he was in that
conversation before he got hurt and
right now is him be honest
LeBron you know those guys man they're
back in that he's back in that
conversation there's the best player in
the world playing it simple
what would you do if you're on Kawhi
Leonard I see in Canada he got to
arguably the best general manager in the
NBA guy know how to draft players first
time in NBA history since 1966 not any
player in the owner team which went
before 14 that's amazing that that guy
can have all those good players I mean
obviously don't do it bicep you got to
have a great scout and staff but to be
able to get to the championship with no
player drafted higher than 14 that got
in first of all listen I know it's a lot
of it we don't want to get his man
credit but we decide Masai Ujiri did
this year is one of the coolest poker
moves in the history of sport that man
could have kept the Martin Rosen 150
games and lost in the playoffs and kept
his job for another ten years everybody
would have been happy but to trade his
best player for a superstar fire the
coach of the year put all his chips in
the middle of the table a nice addition
Marc Gasol to don't forget that because
you know they're you know how these
jackasses and idiots and fools work in
our business if Toronto gets beat do you
know how they are the idiots in our
business our big gonna crush him
they're gonna crush him but he had the
courage and conviction to put all his
chips in the middle of the table that
I'm bad no mean and he cannot get enough
credit like I say nice addition going
out getting Marc Gasol who played
fantastic
so shout out to massage chair man I no
disrespect RC briefings fantastic Sam
Presti is fantastic but what Masai Ujiri
did in the last year is one of the great
Cool Hand Luke movies about moves of all
times well I also wondered Charles as we
move forward if I'm someone like Denver
let's say or Portland or somebody like
take a risk and go after Anthony Davis
even if it's for a one year rental
that's what Toronto did if I think my
team is there and a chance to elevate to
be something special
why wouldn't I roll the dice and try to
win a championship just like Toronto did
you see other teams maybe following suit
and not just saying it's a foregone
conclusion Anthony Davis is going to the
Lakers well clearly the clutch group is
trying to force the NBA to let him go to
LA which I'm not happy with that to be
honest with you we can't have Aegis
dictate and trades you know you can
demand a tree but you don't get to
dictate where they go I have a hard
serious problem with that like they just
have a right if they haven't won a
player traded but you just can't keep
stacking your roster to help your
friends I have a strong disagreement
with that the problem with Anthony Davis
is he's a clutch guy they want him with
the Lakers how much did you give up you
got to understand some he didn't give up
a lot to get Kawhi no so that's a
totally different animal do you give up
your whole roster and after Davis leaves
in a year that's a totally different
thing
so the I'm not sure how to ask you a
question truthfully but you can't just
give you a whole roster away if Alice
Davis gonna leave in a year who do you
think should be the favorite next year
knowing what we know and knowing what we
don't know is gonna happen this
offseason who would you list as the
favor or
they're Co favors next year oh my god
that's one of the craziest questions I
mean well you don't know a person I
talked to today that's the craziest
question I've ever been asked I got no
idea
I mean nobody knows what the hell gonna
happen in the next month so it's just
really just guessing yeah because you
can say a team like Milwaukee everybody
on Milwaukee's team as a free agent yeah
you know you look at the Celtics you
know I think Kerry's already opted out
so you really don't know anything there
with the Celtics so anybody tell you
right now who's gonna hook should be
favored I mean I was you know the team I
pick to come out of the West Portland if
they get nergic back and keep can't turn
hood they might be the favorite in the
West but they're all the team's pretty
much I think Cantor's a free agent but I
think everybody else on that team is
coming back I mean the Warriors are the
Warriors little team has got some
serious question to ask you know what
you do about you know KB I was number
one and what you do about clay is number
two because I think you've got to be
realistic you know both of those guys
deserve the max they deserve the max but
I don't know if you go see them next
year at all yeah I was wondering about
that with that injury with the torn ACL
they said six to nine months but Tim
Legler was on last hour and he said I
don't know if you see Durant or klay
Thompson which leads me to should clay
Thompson have been out there do you have
any problem where he injures the
hamstring and then injures the knee on
that same leg well you know Dan like I
say obviously you know all these things
are related you asked any doctor tell
you something hurting on your leg your
body automatically gonna compensate
automatically not do you think it even
you thinking about it your body
automatically gonna compensate
listen clay wanted to play they give him
out one game he came back and played
a couple a couple games so listen I
think this is totally different than the
Cadiz situation where he hadn't played
basketball in a month I had one little
fake scrimmage I think that's a totally
different animal I've already said I
think there was 100 percent wrong with
putting Katy out there but clays a
little different animal now the most
important reason why I'm having you on
you were at the Stanley Cup final and
you had two blue shirts on you had a
golf shirt and then you had a dress
shirt over the golf shirt yeah what
happened was you know when you go to
hockey games as cold as hell so I didn't
bring a t-shirt to wear under my light
blue shirt I only had a golf shirt with
me and unfortunately when I got to the
game I have no idea where I was hot in
the commissioners box so I had to make a
decision whether to take the Gossard off
so I just open it up I didn't worry
about it because I was feeling pretty I
was feeling some type of way you know I
started drinking like two hours before
the game so I really wasn't worried
about my physical attired and I was
feeling good
so I heard funny because I do know
social media and my friends like killing
you on social media I'm like dude you
know I don't do any social media like
they kill you with your blue light blue
and dark blue but I thought it was
hilarious but I say you know normally
you go to hockey game it's always
freezing that's what we done
I want to thank Commissioner Bettman
again for the tickets at the last minute
he's always been a friend I try to go to
three or four hockey games a year in the
Stanley Cup playoffs and man I couldn't
I never been to game sevens and early
rounds but one game to win the Stanley
Cup man it was pretty cool and the city
of Boston was on fire that day and
congratulations to the st. Louis Blues
and shout out to my board Craig for Ruby
who played by the Flyers I was happy for
him so it was it was awesome being there
can you skate
what kind of hockey player would you
have made I'm a man black people don't
skate stop it a couple of them do hey
mum hey mum labour Byfuglien PK Subin oh
those are black you do black maybe you
know I saw PK up in Toronto man what a
good dude
well yeah no Canadian does it count down
okay stop it
all right I'm curious about that hey
great to talk to you
enjoy the offseason I don't think Fritzi
will bother you for a little while I
have no more interviews to do I probably
the next thing I think people start
calling me again do a free agency so
it's going to be nice you know that
anytime Christine wants me I always take
his call you know I got some friends at
Espen my man Josh at Espen he calls but
listen I'm going to I'm excited to get
like three weeks off well I think
there's about three weeks for full free
agency but hey this creative things just
got really interesting didn't it yeah
yeah it's crazy
cuz I need that you know what it teaches
those sorry teams
how about drafting well and making good
treats instead of just sucking up to
place save it all his money and trying
to you know poach off other teams
this is a good this could be a good
learning lesson why don't you just draft
think about it was a perfect perfect
sample messiah giri makes phrase and
drop his own players and make them
better he knows to make his team suck
and try to go after free agents so this
is gonna be a great lesson for autumn
team who's been sucking up the NBA for
the last year and a half trying to get
all this max salary cap space I can't
wait to start laughing in their face
once free agency hit when they gonna
suck for the next few years
Thank You Charles thank you brother
you two happy Father's Day that's a
Charles Barkley joining us for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]